[Music]
want to know how i become great
watch me
that is top college football recruit
jaquinci mckinstry he goes by the
nickname
kool-aid and he'll be playing for the
university of alabama's crimson tide
this fall
he has also been named the best football
defensive player of the year for usa
today's high school sports awards
and he joins us only on cbs this morning
coulee good morning congratulations
good morning thank you for the award
well we we didn't give it to you but
we'll take credit for it
i got to start with the nickname before
i go anywhere because i've read two
different stories about how you got it
how did the nickname kool-aid come about
um well the day i was born i came at my
mom smiling and my grandma said i had a
kool-aid smile
with the name kool-aid i mean that's a
great anybody who knows the kool-aid
are you a kool-aid fan because i feel a
lot of potential opportunities here
yes i am a big kool-aid fan it's
something i always dreamed of
something i always dreamed to be a part
of so hopefully that can happen one day
in the near future
i have a feeling if you play up to
expectations it very
well could you are playing at alabama
this fall and when you announced in your
letter of intent that you were going to
play for the crimson tide you said you
could finally
say that you grew up a fan of the
crimson tide
what was it like when you finally got in
that locker room and started practicing
with that team
well it was a dream to play football at
this level and it also was a dream just
to play for alabama and i was blessed to
be able
to get here and play with the school
that is at such a high level and a
school that i just dreamed of playing of
playing wilk in general i know in
reading a little you say your dream is
also the nfl and along those lines
there's somebody who would like to
say hello and has a little surprise for
you also with an excellent nickname i'm
sure you'll recognize them for those who
don't
rob gronkowski gronk is here with us
gronk goulet what's up man i just want
to say congratulations and also i want
to let you know
that you have also won usa today's best
male
athlete of the year award two so
congratulations man bringing home two
awards from the high school sports
awards show
uh you know i just want to wish you luck
at alabama i was just talking to o.j
howard a fellow tight end here with the
tampa bay buccaneers
and he wanted me to tell you uh he says
what's up
uh he's a fellow crimson tide just like
yourself right now so
congratulations man how does it feel you
excited
i'm very excited man i'm thankful to get
under the award from you and i'm
thankful for you and tell o.j i said hey
how you doing
[Laughter]
gronk you didn't know you were going to
be like the go-between here it's almost
like a text chain
what you know give us some idea this is
you know time you got to get to practice
why did you want to present this award
today
yes well um myself and michael strahan
we actually hosted the high school
sports awards show which airs tonight's
streams tonight
uh so i just wanted you know to have the
honor to congratulate kool-aid for uh
you know
being the top male athlete out there in
high school and just congratulating on
him on all his hard work and dedication
that you know he has provided
um and just to keep it going man just
keep working hard just keep doing
what you need to do listen to the
coaches uh go out there and just try to
be a team player
uh every aspect on the football field
and you'll be successful man just keep
doing you
koolaid i can't tell you i can't tell if
you're in shock
or if you're just very low-key what does
it mean to you
because we love gronk around here it's
really good to see you rob gronkowski
what does it mean to you kool-aid to
have
rob present this to you
um it means a lot man i mean i play with
the um buccaneers on man
i use them a lot when i go trey
formation
on the corner route so this this means a
lot to me
yeah i think so too i think so too what
do you
what are you most looking forward to as
you head to alabama and then
gronk rob what advice do you have for
him as he goes out on the field but you
go first kool-aid
because i hear you play basketball too
well what are you
looking forward to most as you get ready
to play because i hear you play
basketball too
i'm just looking forward to helping the
team and doing whatever i can
do to help the team out and on the
basketball side the same thing i just
want to do what i can do
to help the team all right rob
gronkowski before you go can you just
tell us about that super bowl ring
that thing was insane i'd never seen
anything like that what was it like when
you saw it for the first time
uh i was shocked i was mind blown i mean
they just did a terrific job
the buccaneers they're just a first
class organization and
and they do excellence with everything
they do and the super bowl ring
uh it was just a plus um it was
mind-blowing and uh just the way that
you know it portrays the season and you
know all the gold
and the silver in it it just it just
looks beautiful i know and where are you
going to wear it too
you don't have to wear it i'm going to
shake shack where are you going
hello can i get a oreo milkshake please
holding up my super bowl ringstock you
might get better service that way
because they're gigantic it's like a
finger workout when you're wearing all
the rings
it it looks like it rob thank you so
much he's got to go to practice that's
right
go get on the field there we appreciate
the time kool-aid congratulations
to you again on the awards and good luck
this season with alabama good luck
cheering you on kool-aid that's right
and you can watch usa today's high
school sports awards show tonight on
usatoday.com